[Wes] Ok, I'm here at Mozilla, which is responsible for the Open Source Firefox web browser.
And it's also where we find Brendan Eich, the designer of JavaScript.
Let's go in to learn more about that language.
So in this class we handle a very restricted subset of JavaScript.
For example, we don't pay very much attention, or any attention to the Document Object Model.
One question that one might have is: how really useful is to focus on a subset
of Javascript or HTML.
Can the skills that we'll learn in making a lexer, a parser, an interpreter for a smaller language
carry over for important tasks in the real world.
[Brendan]The answer is yes. Mozilla and other working browser in the Web
often are doing with a subset of JavaScript.
There is a subset, not quite a subset, called JSON
that is quite popular, for describing trees of data.
And it turns out that we want to parse JSON very quickly
in order to have Javascript to "eval()".
So, in our implementation we actually do a very quick subset's parse in the middle
of line for JSON, because that's such a common case.
And if we can parse this JSON, which is asubset, JavaScript would be much more efficient.
I also observed a lot of JavaScript libraries, that have almost 'query' in their name,
are doing a sort of compiled generated functions that are optimized to match
certain queries against the Document Object Model.
And so there's co-generation going on.
There are some partial evaluations going on, there is a subset of the language been used
to construct simple matches and rules, for matching trees.